- What were some of your
first jobs in New York?
- Well, I was a guard at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art.
- Oh!
- Yes.
When I was 21 years old,
right out of college,
and I studied theater and I, I,
I got in a play and I thought that I could
work the midnight to eight
in the morning shift.
You know what that shift is called?
The graveyard shift, right?
- Yes, I've had that shift in jobs. Yes.
- You have?
- Yes.
- So I thought I could do
it, 'cause I was very young.
I thought I could go,
rehearse, do the play,
do the midnight to eight in the mor-
Well, the third night of that,
they found me asleep
on a 300 year old bed.
- Oh no.
- Yeah.
A work of art, like in
one of the period rooms.
- Oh my God.
- Yes. And I was fired.
- Oh. (laughing)
- Yes.
That's what happens, Kelly,
when fall asleep on the art.
Yes, I was. And, and,
but later, here's the lesson.
Years later when I became a writer,
I needed to write a sample script.
So I had a partner out here in Hollywood.
What are we going to write about?
Well, there was a show called Roseanne
that was on at the time,
the first iteration of Roseanne.
And I thought, what if John
Goodman's character gets a
second job at the local museum,
And he falls asleep on a 300 year old bed?
And we wrote that, and we
started sending it around,
and people were going,
"what an imagination!"
That's great.
- You're like, "yeah,
I totally thought it up."
- We got hired. So my
most humiliating moment
of my life became my ticket to everything.
- But that's smart. I call
that clever. That's using--
- But people, you can take terrible things
that happened in your
life and turn them into--
- Yeah! Songs. And yeah, that's what I do.
- Is it? All of country
music is that, isn't it?
- Yeah, all of pop and country, yeah.